would you be willing to show us
you do the humming at the same time
i know i'm very impressive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i had this thing i would do to make my
my family members and friends laugh it
was called the helium voice okay and uh
i used to love to do that as a kid with
the balloons yeah it's like that and i
would break into the course uh you know
we all live in the yellow submarine in
the helium voice
so you wha what is that well i gotta let
me see if i can get let me see if i can
get my helium back on okay
you can just do it
[Music]
below
[Music]
and everybody
it still works
it still works
[Applause]
i want to know how you eat a cupcake
because i hear you eat one differently
and i want to learn obi-wan okay so i
didn't realize that this was that
unusual until i was at my friend's
steph's 40th birthday okay and it got
omicron so we couldn't have a cake so we
did uh
i'm a crunch i got omicron
and uh so i
took my cupcake and i was sat there and
we were having a conversation and i did
this thing and it stopped the party now
i have stopped parties before but never
for a good reason and this was a good
way to stop a party so you take the top
oh and you pull it apart and then you
flip it
you like a like a whoopie pie almost
like you and then you have a sandwich
and you don't get frosting up your nose
so i have a scatter tonic sense of humor
does anyone know what that means a
scatter tonic sensitivity like pee wee
herman right now with word of the day i
know right skeleton
it means that you know when someone does
a fart joke
oh okay okay you just can't stop
laughing i am into fart jokes i think
that's me too right so uh and uh so this
is my party trick
hmm
it's being able to do it without
you know your eyebrows are going to stay
still you got to look really just
my favorite part is the slide-off slide
is
when i'm acting you know and you know
the countdown is like okay turn it over
speed camera and
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
so wait what one thing well before idle
one thing we have in common is you
waited tables right yes so me too okay
yeah i feel like we have a lot of
similarities and were you a good
waitress do you think i was a great
waitress too i was yeah
i was i missed i was pretty good yeah
thank you yeah
yeah
and we were i and i was working for that
tip girl
100.
and um and i know that you like uh you
enjoy your wine i really do amy yeah i
really do
now do you guys have that you have like
a thing like a whole thing used to do
with wine i'm still kind of proud of the
fact and i mean of course i'm going to
screw it up now because i'm doing it on
tv but i'm kind of proud of the fact
that i can open a bottle of wine and
tell you about the specials and distract
you from the fact that i'm not doing a
great job opening the line
you're an actor because you know those
couple times when you've been opening
wine and then the
cork like you get half
and you're like and you're like just one
second i just have to go check something
in the kitchen
like with a knife
luckily you worked at nice places um i
work at a comedy club and so mine were
like there was no it was whiskey and
yeah but you know what i happen to i
mean it's weird interesting but
um
i haven't asked this fine acne line i
think we've hidden some some stuff to
help you out what do we have underneath
i mean let's celebrate oh my goodness
yes let's celebrate
amazing okay
okay here's your wine i say we celebrate
smart girls let's do it
i never had to do this as a waitress i
would have vomited i've never never had
to do this no i'm seriously it was not
fancy at all nobody ordered they weren't
bud light amy
so you never took the bud light and you
did never show it
i don't know why we're drinking here
this looks like somebody's good wine
okay okay let's do it so um just a
couple specials we have today
um
[Laughter]
do you have any pasta we do have a
delicious gnocchi is it gluten-free
we can make it gluten-free we can make
it gluten-free or we can tell you it's
gluten-free and you'll never know that
exactly until i'm bloated the next day
yeah
let's see we have a branzino tonight
that's amazing it's served fully full
not cooked
and you have to cook it yourself it's
like a mini hannah yeah we have to go
catch it but it's so fresh don't you
love fishing
[Laughter]
we have what else do we have today we
have a roasted um sirloin
with like possibly some risottos yeah
we've reserved soda we have risotto ice
cream which is weird
ice cream but i'm into it
yeah like and then like also i'm trying
to help you out
[Applause]
you know what's so interesting about
bread
you know it's great
right here
you know what's so interesting about
bread
is it really fills you up it does yeah
to where you don't have to eat the meal
you're just like jesus bread and wine so
um okay uh
let me guess your birthday okay um
you must be a tourist
okay okay and now
yes i don't i don't make friends drink
alone so i'll definitely i'm gonna go
this is gonna make me go night night i
can't wait okay
is that so wrong though a nap no no
[Applause]
okay okay what was your what was your
local mall
local mall when you he was hugely mall
hulen hulen mall and what was your
favorite uh like
food at the food local was like 40
minutes away but yeah i know how it
works a small town what my food food
court what did you eat at the food court
i didn't eat at the mall i was poor i
just window shopped
what did you eat at the food court
panda express oh okay okay okay
favorite dish
uh was like orange chicken yeah you
better believe it love them okay and now
for both of you first cd that you that
you ever got cds are compact don't worry
about it
i was going to say prime boys to
mid-motown philly love it okay spice
girls nice
[Music]
what was the first one spice up your
spice world
spice up your life so i swirled spice
world you know what we'll just say spicy
just give me a
were you guys yeah let's just do
something like
oh my god yeah okay uh here we are here
we are here we go
[Music]
now once upon a time not long ago before
the idol and the kelly clarkson show
yeah my girl what was she doing going to
the mall yeah it was called hulen
what's she there for she's at a window
shop cause she's all so poor
oh yeah so yes i was my girl vanessa was
over at the panda express looking so
good yeah she finger licking go up to
the counter get that orange chicken
what you do with me you see i'm boys to
men listening to motown philly oh
oh so nice i'm on the mic and i'm
crazier than scary spice and ginger head
bringer i am the bringer i'll do it all
day long that's right i never linger i'm
here mr indians so full of melanin i
rock up on the microphone i came to spit
without the pen but anyway i think i'm
done i'm broken and i'm beautiful
that was my musical
that's actually crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
you